today we take rolling luggage with us
everywhere we travel they take the heavy
lifting out of a trip so it feels more
like a vacation
these hardshell rolling bags start with
polypropylene pellets they add a small
amount of colored polypropylene pellets
to the uncolored ones they'll act as a
dye for the batch they mix and melt the
polypropylene pellets into a thick blue
liquid then it's over to the injection
molding system the molds close and a
nozzle injects the liquid polypropylene
the molds are equipped with a cooling
system so that the polypropylene hardens
almost instantly into a lightweight yet
durable material a pile of pellets
becomes half of a luggage shell in mere
seconds arroba transfers the molded
shell to the next station
he now screws the service handle into
it's molded slot this handle is for
those times when the traveler has to
lift the bag by hand upstairs or onto a
baggage belt these triangular molded
parts are the side feet they'll keep the
luggage upright he fastens them onto the
base of the shell it's time to close
this bag he adds the other half he
threads a steel rod into hinge holes to
hold the two shells together next they
mold wheels from nylon a robot transfers
the wheels to another part of the mall
the mold closes and Inasa pipes in hot
liquid rubber to apply it to the rolling
surface of the wheels the rubber adheres
to the nylon and solidifies they attach
two wheels to a polypropylene hub for
stable swiveling action
a factory worker now inserts an
extendable handle then working from the
inside she screws the handle to the
luggage shell she reinforces the
connection with a metal bracket ensuring
that the extendable handle will hold
fast even when the load is heavy she
plugs the wheels into their slots in the
base of the luggage she secures them
with screws this bag is now mobile with
360-degree swiveling action